minute there's still a few people
joining
yeah there's that standard issue that
people have to walk back from
their lunch place in berkeley usually
yeah that excuse sort of doesn't really
work these days but yeah
okay yeah let's get started uh so
thanks everyone for coming back and uh
it's a pleasure to have
thomas who are you in seattle thomas
uh let me look outside it's 2 p.m it's
completely dark yes i
am okay so yeah uh
i think there are similar latitudes in
germany where it gets dark as early but
it's so uh
yeah so uh so we're thomas and i are in
the same city but i haven't seen you for
at least
six months uh in any case uh he'll tell
us about
galaxy and measure partial colorings and
linear size sparsifiers
okay um thanks a lot for having me and
um
so what i'm going to talk about today
it's a it's a collection of
results from three papers and two of
them are
joined with my graduate student victor
rice
um so at least for me everything uh
so the motivation started because i was
interested
in uh discrepancy theory which is a
subfield of
combinatorics and usually the setting
goes as follows
you have a you have a set system with a
finite number of sets
over some finite ground set and
now you're asked to find the coloring
of the elements with two colors red and
blue or
minus one and plus one if you like so
that
uh you're you're trying to color these
sets as evenly as possible
and really what counts is the the set
that has the
uh the maximum imbalance so what you're
trying to
uh to optimize is you're trying to
minimize
over all the colorings of the elements
and then the uh
you count the maximum imbalance of any
set in your set system
and there's just two classical results
that i would like to mention
there's one by spencer from the mid 80s
which says that well
you have in arbitrary you have an
arbitrary sets over n elements
then uh this discrepancy is always
bounded by a constant times through that
and there's another nice result which is
that
well if you have a special property that
every element is in that most t
sets then you can prove that the
discrepancy is bounded by 2t
and spencer's result is interesting in
the sense that this beats what a random
coloring would do
so this is not just a fancy analysis of
a random coloring this is something
kind of smarter and
the main technique in this field and
this is also
the technique behind spencer's result is
the
partial coloring method the partial
coloring method
sort of in in spirit is it says the
following you
you don't shoot directly for full
coloring you
are you're happy by coloring a constant
fraction of the elements
and having a little discrepancy and uh
then you take the coloring for that
constant fraction of the elements you
color the elements you throw them away
and then
then you repeat and this is also how
yeah
this is how you can get for example
spencer's result
uh okay um
here's uh in my opinion the uh
sort of a right way how you how you
state the partial coloring
result and this is sort of where things
move towards uh the convex
geometry side of things and
here's a theory in which in
in this statement itself is
due due to is a later statement due to
genopolis and but it's
it's uh sort of implicitly proven a
little bit by by glasgow and spencer
earlier
so what it says is that well you uh take
uh
symmetry convex body k in uh r to the n
and uh you uh you promise me that the
gaussian measure is not too small
so that's let's say at least e to the
minus
a small enough constant times n then
there exists a partial coloring in k
partial coloring means some coordinates
are minus 1 0
1 and the support of of that partial
covering is at least a constant fraction
a decent constant fraction okay and
uh so here's a little bit of picture you
have your
submitted connect set and you you might
find a partial coloring like this
okay the proof is based on
the pigeonhole principle and in
particular
it's a non-algorithmic proof and
i still would not know an algorithm that
would give you this partial coloring as
as promised here
okay um it'll be worth
keeping in mind that this this constant
here in the exponent this actually
this needs to be uh decently small
if it's uh above some threshold that i
don't have in the top of my head then
this theorem is not going to work
okay um since i'm
sort of coming a bit from the computer
science side i'm actually interested in
um in algorithmic versions of these uh
discrepancy theories
discrepancy theorems and so here's one
that i'm going to
going to explain today
will prove the following that uh well
you take a symmetry convex set k and
the gaussian measure is at least e to
the minus alpha n
where alpha now is an arbitrarily large
constant
okay so there's a bit more flexibility
then we can find a partial coloring
that's in some
constant scaling of k
and a constant fraction of the
coordinates are going to be
on the uh the boundary they're going to
be plus one or minus one
and uh important thing is we can do this
in polling over time
okay so picture is uh slightly different
now
uh we're not actually finding a coloring
where
uh the coordinates are in minus one zero
one we're
sort of finding a coloring where the
coordinates are between minus one and
one
with sort of enough entries on the on
the extremes
okay uh good
um one comment is that
uh it's a little bit what i said earlier
is that
in this form uh janopolo's result is
actually not
true um you could for example if you
take
k as all the points that are close
enough to some
hyperplane with some awkward enough
normal vector
then um there's not going to be a
zero minus one one point on that
hyperplane other than the origin
even if you scale it by uh more than the
concept
okay good uh
so this will be part one of the talk is
uh is going
uh to prove this result and uh please
interrupt me if there any
questions uh
okay um
so here's the algorithm and um
i like to talk about the algorithm
because it has only two lines
that doesn't really happen very often
these days in the theoretical computer
science
um okay so here's the setup i'm i'm
actually
uh i'm actually not scaling k
rather i scale the cube okay
so i change the setting to something
that's equivalent i'm finding
a partial color in k intersected the
cube with side length to epsilon
and i can choose the epsilon and i can
choose the delta dependent on alpha
so that uh i can make things fit okay
good so here's the algorithm
i i take a random gaussian
let's call it x star covariance is the
identity and
you can kind of see from the picture
that this random gaussian with
hyperbolitis
it's going to lie way outside of the
cube and sort of way outside of k
but now i do the following i
compute uh the
point y y star uh that's
lying in k intersected by cube and
that's
as close to xr as possible
okay um so if you look at the statement
then
this point sort of trivially uh
satisfies that it's in
in k and dissected the cube but why on
earth
actually would many of the coordinates
uh be
sort of on the boundary of the cube this
is the this is all of the
the interesting part
and maybe maybe one comment
about why is this a polynomial algorithm
is that well this is a this is a convex
minimization problem here
so you're minimizing uh a convex
uh objective function and y is in the
intersection of two convex set
so this is really just context
programming uh and this
can be done in time uh let's say minus
some numerical issues
okay uh good
and i'm gonna explain you why this
algorithm actually works and then the
second part of the talk
i'll give you some application of it
okay um
good um here are some facts and uh
some notation uh that i'm going to use
um this notation gamma n of k
uh this is uh this is the gaussian
measure we're really just
picking the gaussian with zero
covariance
is the identity um
there is a something else i'm going to
use is that
if you have two symmetric convex sets a
and b
then the gaussian measure of their
intersection
is at least the product of the gaussian
measures
this is interestingly this is uh this is
a very
uh recent theorem uh
proven by i believe a retired
german community college professor
uh it was known a long time earlier with
uh when one of the sets was a strip and
well this is actually the only case that
we would be using
um but it's just a very useful fact to
know
so this is something the picture you may
want to keep in mind
okay
finally uh i'll use the width
of a convex symmetric body this
is a quantity that i'll define as
follows you take a random direction x
uh you're averaging over x and you you
see
uh what inner product can i get with x
with any point in k
and um this is sort of a it's a good
measure how large a convex body is and
this is a
measure that also works kind of nicely
if you have a sort of lower dimensional
convex bodies okay
um finally there's a beautiful
theorem due to a urizon and
it says that i mean at least the version
that i'm using says that
among convex bodies with identical
gaussian measure
uh the body that minimizes the width
it's the euclidean ball of
the right radius that's centered at the
origin
okay and
uh okay maybe some disclaimer
i know this theorem by uh
this is a i learned this from paper by
uh
singh and el and ron aldan and they
already have the inside that the uh
the the the width of the con of our
context body is sort of a
it's a good quantity to look at if you
if you care about these uh
fractional colorings
okay good so this is just a little bit
of a
couple of notations that i need and
so we can now come to the main part
of the analysis which fits on one slide
and then i did one one exercise to
kind of justify all of the inequalities
okay so here we are this is uh
this is my uh semantic convex body this
is my cube
and uh now let's talk about what the
algorithm is doing
again the algorithm picks a random
gaussian x star
and then it kind of looks at the
projection of that
uh vector x star on the intersection of
k
and the cube and
let's discuss a little bit what is
actually the euclidean distance
between x star and y star that we would
expect
first of all i claim that it's it's not
very hard to get
some lower bound on at least
the the expected distance because you
can simply lower bound the expected
distance of x star to the cube
and then you can really just analyze
coordinate wise how far is one
coordinate
from uh the interval minus epsilon
epsilon
you add things up and you get the
expected uh
you get a low bound on the expected
square distance and then you use
concentration
uh that actually with very high
probability
my random gaussian has a distance from k
intersect at the cube which is at least
one minus
let's say five epsilon times root n okay
in particular this is sort of
proportional to root n which we kind of
would expect and it kind of goes
approaches
root n if you send the absolute to zero
so it's not a surprising quantity
okay ah good
um so this is a lower bound so let's
talk about an upper bound
um so this distance of x
star and y star this is as i pointed out
this is actually obtained
by solving convex optimization problem
and this is important not only because
you can solve convex optimization
problems completely over time
convex optimization problems also have
the following nice property that
um whenever you have a constraint
that's not tied for your optimum you can
throw that constraint out
and your optimum doesn't change the
optimum value doesn't change
definitely okay good so
uh let's look at this so the constraints
that we have is that well y has to be in
k
and the coordinates of y
have to be between minus epsilon and
epsilon
and now let's throw out all the all
these constraints that are not high for
the optimal
okay then uh
really what what you have is that well
y star is the closest point to x star
that lies in k
intersected well only the app the strips
of width
to epsilon that belong to the tight
constraints
and um our algorithm only fails if
they're actually very very few of these
tight constraints
so this is sort of where we get some
some leverage
okay good let's make this a little bit
more formal
let's say uh i star these are
all the coordinates where uh
uh y star lies on the boundary of the
cube
and let's assume for the sake of
contradiction that this set is very very
small it's at most delta n
and we can make delta as small as we
like
uh okay good
and uh let's say um k of i star that's
the
sort of dark blue set here this is a k
intersected all these
uh few strips where our coordinates are
between minus epsilon and epsilon
um good we can do a small site
calculation and
estimate what is actually the gaussian
measure of this set
k of i star and
that's where we use uh the one of the
inequalities that i mentioned earlier
so this is just we can lure bound this
by taking just the product of the
gaussian measure
of of k which we know is sort of
decently large
and then the gaussian measure of all the
strips
okay so this is a one-dimensional
quantity that's not hard to get a lower
bond
in terms of epsilon and the number
number of strips we have is that both
delta n and we can make delta
as small as we like so we can get some
kind of lower bound
and yeah good
okay so what does it give us well
actually if you think about this then
you you have a
symmetry convex body and the uh you have
some lower bound on the gaussian measure
then by by concentration you can get
some upper bound on the distance
of uh of a random gaussian to this body
okay and i'm going to do this a little
bit more carefully in the next slide but
i promise that well we can choose
absolute delta as we like so in
particular we can show that
with very high probability the distance
of the random gaussian
to such a body k of i star it's less
than one minus
say 10 epsilon and
the important thing here is that well uh
the 10 is bigger than the five
so uh this sort of looks already like
we're at a contradiction
because um if the algorithm fails
then we're sort of very close to the
like the distance is actually very close
on the other hand we have a lower bound
on the distance
uh okay um
there's one uh thing where one has to be
slightly careful is that
well um this index that i start it
actually
depends on x star so we cannot
fix the index set i star then pick the
random gaussian i star
but as the probability that x star
is far from k i star is exponentially
small
we can simply run the union bound over
all
index sets that have size at most tiny
constant times n
and with very high probability actually
x star
is uh going to be rather close to all
bodies
of the form k of i where i is a small
enough index set
okay uh that's uh
pretty much the proof mine is the issue
that um
i i can explain a little bit more
details why
uh we should expect that a random
gaussian is sort of
close enough to convex body and one has
to be a little bit careful with the
parameters then yeah
okay uh so there's a
uh there's a just one lemma that i need
and
i'm actually not convinced that this
lemma is new so this uh
i'm pretty sure this could be found
somewhere
but anyway um so the only thing we
actually
uh need to show is that well you have a
convex symmetric body q q is this body k
of i happens to be it and we have some
lower bound on the gaussian measure
then we can get an upper bound on
the expected distance of a random
gaussian
the important thing is that actually i
need an upper bound that's
better than root n and it needs to be
better
by some constant and no matter what
constant alpha i have here
anyway it's not uh not too difficult
[Music]
you can reason as follows you take this
body q
ah you can assume that's within some
ball
of radius root n times something
dependent on alpha
uh simply because you you could just cut
off whatever is outside and
you wouldn't lose more than this
e to the minus alpha ah
okay good now uh
by eurozone's inequality you can
essentially turn the lower bound on the
gaussian measure into
a lower bound on the width and
[Music]
basically by simply looking at a
at a ball of well
this uh that has the gauge measure of
this quantity and then
uh then you do one line calculation what
would actually be the width of this
uh this euclidean bar okay
so this is something that's rather
friendly to
us and
now how do we argue that
that a random gaussian is is close to q
well um horizon's inequality gives us
the following that well
if we take a random gaussian then we can
actually
cook up some point in q that has a
decently large inner product
with our gaussian so that isn't the same
as
having a closed point uh but it's
helpful
okay here's a little bit of a picture
imagine this is our random gaussian
this here is q and this point
uh z of x this is the one that has a
decently large inner product with with x
okay uh good
uh so we cannot directly argue that this
point z of x is close to x
but we can sort of interpolate and we
can take some convex combination between
the origin
and and this point instead of
x and we can simply estimate what is
the expected uh square distance between
our gaussian and this point uh
set of x and if you multiply things out
then you get that this is the
expected square length of the gaussian
which we know minus and this is
important
uh a linear term in lambda times uh
the expected inner product of x with
this point
in q and we have a lower bound on this
expectation and uh there is some
quadratic sort of error term that
we can upper bound essentially by the
radius
uh of q and then you can see that well
we're sort of gaining something that's
linear lambda so you should
pick the suitable uh value for lambda
and then
you can get some lower bound which is a
little bit better than n
and uh then you take the square root and
you sense this inequality and then
then you get the claim that we actually
want to have okay
good uh
and that is the end of part one
of my talk and if there are any
questions this would not be a bad time
okay uh good
so this is a fairly general algorithm to
find um
fractional partial colorings in um and
convex bodies
uh might not be too bad to have at least
one example where this
can give you uh something maybe a
combinatorial setting and um
i can show you one and this is a
two this is about the linear size
specifies the graphs
um alright the the question i thought
yes
it was answered never mind
okay okay good uh
okay so here is one of my uh my all-time
favorite theorems uh this is due to
a pattern spearman and srivastava
and this theorem says the following you
take any undirected graph g
then the following is possible you can
find
a sub graph with only n over epsilon
square many edges
and you can put some weights on the
edges some non-negative weights on the
edge on the edges of this parcel graph
so that for every cut
the value of the
cut in the original graph is
approximately
up to one plus epsilon error it's
approximately the weighted cut
in the spacer graph
immensely useful theorem for um
variants of this are used to find uh
fast uh maximum flows and graphs
um if you if you look at this
uh this small example where i have two
clicks connected by an edge
if you imagine how could such a
specifier look in the graph
then you can convince yourself that the
picture has to be that
the result has to pick that connecting
edge
and the only way it can put there is
something that's rather close to one
on the other hand the uh the two clicks
if you're specifying the two clicks that
well at least on average
um the weights that you put on these
edges have to be rather high
um so that already shows you that you
cannot
at least you cannot in every setting get
a get a uniform sparsifier so it's not
that
you take a sub graph and you put the
same value on every edge that wouldn't
work
and i should also point out that what
they're actually proving is something
stronger
they actually prove that the laplacian
of the sparse graph
is weighted um it approximates the
laplacian of the original graph which is
a
it's a stronger statement than saying
that for every cut
this approximation holds true
okay ah good
so um what uh bats and spearmints
rastavat do is
they actually prove um a linear algebra
result
which itself is very interesting and it
says the following that
you take vectors m vectors uh
that are sort of in in isotropic
position let's call it that way
meaning that if you sum up the vector
vectors v i v i transpose then
you get the identity now what they
they show is that well in polynomial
time you can find
uh find where a weight vector and
non-negative weight vector s
so that the support is bounded by n over
epsilon square
and um if you put these weights in front
of the
these uh rank 1 matrices then you get
something that's approximately
the identity uh up to one plus x not
factor
and uh this sign here this this is the
leuven ordering
uh okay and we can
in in some sense i claim that we can
uh recover this result from like a
convex geometry perspective
okay uh
and uh here's essentially the algorithm
uh we can do things slightly more
general
let's say you uh take some uh positive
semi-definite matrices a
i and so that they sum up to the
identity
and you give me some parameter epsilon
now uh let's look at the following body
k
so this is uh the set of all vectors x
in
one number of matrices many dimensions
so that if you put all these
if you sum up the matrices a i weighted
by x i
and you you take the uh the maximum
singular value this is upper bound
by uh think of this as being epsilon
okay so for me this is this is a this is
the the body of good partial colorings
and what we now do is
we find a fraction of partial coloring
and we can flip the sign if necessary so
that
a lot of the coordinates are actually
minus one
and now we do the following we
replace the ith matrix by
uh a i plus y i a i
so what this means is that whenever we
had a coordinate which is minus one
then actually the uh this matrix drops
down to zero like the weight drops on to
zero
okay you uh i hope you can see that
if you do this step uh once then
you're specifying the sum here
a constant fraction of these matrices
are going to disappear
others are being scaled a little bit by
something
and maybe we're not getting the identity
but we're getting something that's
actually rather close
to the identity okay
in some sense this is a specification
argument
that cuts down the support by constant
fraction
and if you really want to go down until
uh your support reaches n over epsilon
squared then you sort of
uh then you iterate this argument until
you're there
and uh maybe it's worth noting that
um sort of this quantity root n over m
um if m is very large you might actually
start with something that's very small
and then it grows growth growth grows so
it's kind of the arrow that you're doing
it's dominated by the very last step
where uh the size of m is approximately
n over epsilon
square so this is why you can you can
think of this as being epsilon
i want to consider the interesting case
good
okay so uh in principle
this argument this algorithm would work
we would need uh
essentially only a logarithmic number of
iterations
and this uh procedure would output uh
kind of a one plus epsilon specifier uh
of the matrices and you could also use
that to get a
uh specifier of a of a graph if you want
it
um the only thing that we need to show
is that actually we can find these
uh we can find these fractal partial
colors they they exist and we can find
them
which is not clear from the picture here
okay good um then let's uh let's
sit down and speculate a little bit um
so what we actually know about sets of
the form
you know all vectors x so that the sum
over
x i a i has singular values
uh upper bounded by a root nanogram
um okay so
first of all um this is the norm
operator norm is a norm so definitely
the body that we have it's going to be
our convex and it's going to be
symmetric
um unfortunately it's not a polyhedral
body
there are always some some easy
arguments that you can apply if you have
a you have a body that has only a few
faces
a few facets uh so that that's not going
to flock here
and uh i'm afraid my symmetric convex
body
kind of looks pretty similar like all
the others that you've seen in this talk
um okay uh what would be nice to
to to be able to prove would be
wonderful if we could prove
a lower bound on the gaussian measure of
such a set k
um if that was true
then we would simply apply our little
algorithm
sample a random gaussian projected on k
intersect at the
cube this times the minus 1 1 cube and
that would do the job ah problem is
i i do not know if this is true
i would be reasonably sure but i don't
have a proof well on the other hand
if you go back to the analysis of the
algorithm then
uh well this was a very convenient
condition that made the algorithm work
as you you're you're let's say upset
that the
body is non-polyhedral the tool that
takes away from you is just like
complementary slack just like analyzing
tight constraints
like counting type constraints or
um okay so first of all if
uh it was a polyhedral set
then you could just uh apply this uh
lower bound which which is that the the
gaussian measure it's at least the
product of all the strips so let's say
you have a linear number of strips
that that usually would be enough
just from the algorithm i
i don't think that i could use anything
from the
algorithm to say that only like a linear
number
of constraints of k matter
uh it's more like that the cube has a
linear number
of of like constraints that i use but
not really that k has a linear number of
constraints i mean i
i could conclude that
does it give a powershot okay
good um okay so actually
the algorithm that we have seen it would
already work
if we could prove that
k is rather close to most of the
gaussian measure because well that's
actually what the analysis sort of used
uh and
[Music]
so to be precise what we would like is
that the gaussian measure of
let's say some constant scaling of k
plus
some constant that probably should be
less than one times root m
times the ball this should uh reach a
decent fraction of
of the gaussian measure and
to be more precise you need this in a
hereditary sense in the sense that well
even
if you freeze a small constant fraction
of the coordinates this is still true
but in some sense the way we define
things uh it is automatically hereditary
okay so this is a statement that
would make the algorithm work and this
is luckily what we actually can prove
uh okay and uh to be slightly more
precise is what we'll prove is that
for any parameter alpha if you take
50 over alpha times k and you add
uh alpha times root m times
uh the ball in this space then you reach
um
a half of the dash measure okay
and you can pick your favorite alpha
here
this also implies something
something nice in geometric terms for k
it shows that
the width of such a body is large
uh again i still have no idea whether
the gaussian mirror
could be suitably lower bounded but at
least the width is large
uh it's a little bit i have a hard time
imagining
sets where one is true the other one is
not
like the only thing i can imagine is
something that's actually like very thin
in some direction but
this body doesn't really look like it
has that property but
anyway i can't prove that
okay good uh and
uh how much time do i have left maybe
10-15 minutes
uh i can uh try a little bit of the
analysis
um uh thomas can i ask a quick question
um yeah so do you
uh your setting is different right
you're in the psd
setting if you were in the setting of
spielmann
do you know meaning my
matrices ai they would have rank one
i would not know the answer there either
it didn't seem to be simpler to me
thanks thanks thanks
okay good um so here are the rules of
the game
uh we have this symmetrical context by
the k picking a random gaussian
and we have to be proved that with
decent chance the random gaussian
actually is rather close to k
um instead of doing this sort of in a
one-shot argument we
imagine that we are generating this
random gaussian
using using a brownian motion so there's
a little bit of a random walk
and we'll kind of track uh how far we
are
in some sense from k
and uh so here's more of the setup
um okay imagine delta this
is the uh sort of a this is a tiny step
size in my brownie motion
i maintain two vectors a little x and
little z
start with zero and now well
i know that i need one over delta square
many iterations
and in every iteration i
sort of add up some some gaussian steps
and uh what i do is that
i add to x i add delta times
a gaussian with covariance matrix
capital x
and to that i add up a gaussian with
covariance matrix
identity minus capital x in some sense
these
gaussian updates are complementary
good and uh so what the
the picture is doing is that i have
these vectors x and z
and they're sort of moving and in
particular
x plus z this is just the gaussian
this is just gaussian width covariance
matrix identity
and x's naught gaussian
has some other distribution but
if we pick the covariance matrix for
little x if we pick this as something
that's
well upper bounded by the identity and
close enough to the identity meaning
that the trace is at least one minus
alpha square times
m then i could conclude that actually
well in expectation uh the distance
of that real gaussian 2x is rather small
and i will maintain little x so that it
lies in k
okay so i have this little gaussian this
little
brown emotion uh little x stays in k
and then i'm i'm kind of tracking how
far i'm actually away from the real
gaussian
and this is going to make the analysis
easier uh it's important to know that
the this covariance matrix capital x
this is going to
depend on little x so it's going to
depend on where we are
and you can think of this as there are
going to be some dangerous directions
where i don't want to walk into so i
just
uh block them out my gaussian doesn't
work in the gauntlet for little x does
not walk into that direction
okay and
[Music]
yes so that's sort of the intuition of
the analysis
uh okay
um good let's talk a little bit how do
we actually guarantee
that little x stays in k so in
particular what we need to do is
we need to uh be able to upper bound and
lower bound the
uh the eigenvalues of the sum over x i
times a
and um actually we cannot make life a
little bit easier we can
it suffices to only up about the
only upper bound the eigenvalues uh
because
you can take a matrix ai and you can
take minus ai
and you see you get you get bit bigger
matrix that has like twice the dimension
it's not psd but you didn't need that
really in the first place
okay good
um now we're using a potential function
and the potential function is as follows
um
i take my matrix uh this is the the sum
over x i ais and i subtract this from
some scalar of the identity
and then i look at the trace of the
inverse of this matrix that i get
okay and uh
okay then an order to be not sued by
nikki srivastava for a copyright
violation
so these are trace of the inverse matrix
this is already something that appears
in their paper so this sort of is the
right potential function
if you want to kind of control um
eigenvalues in the setting
uh however the updates we're doing are
very different we do gaussian
updates and they only do like monotone
increases of coordinates
okay and here in this in this formula c
and d these are kind of parameters and
you can see that
um as the vector x gets longer i'm sort
of adding a little bit of the identity
okay so why is this potential function
going to be useful
uh well as long as the potential
function is upper bound by anything
finite
i know that this matrix a that depends
on x is going to be uh
positive definite and then i know that
well
the uh the eigenvalues of this
sum of the ai matrices that i have this
is bounded by
c plus dx okay and you can see that
as the vector x sort of gets longer i'm
actually
relaxing my upper bound a little bit
okay good
so far um
i haven't picked my my values of c and d
and uh but the the main lemma that one
can prove
is the following and i'm not insisting
you remember the parameters but
the point is that if the potential
function is upper bounded by
some quantity then i can guarantee that
yes there is a psd matrix x upper
bounded by the identity
trace large enough close enough to the
trace of the identity
so that if i do gaussian updates
then uh with step size delta then in
expectation
the potential function does not go up
meaning in particular if i start by
potential function
at most the threshold then uh it'll
always stay below that
person and uh
i admit that i i do i am swiping
a lot of the technicalities uh under the
iraq in particular you have a potential
function
that has that has poles so
uh with some kind of positive
probability
very very unlikely you get the potential
function is like infinite so it's kind
of a
bit of a problem problems we have to
take the gaussian update you have to
cap it uh at some length but
it cannot be done okay i
uh okay i want to give you a little bit
of an of an intuition and
yeah i i don't think i have a time to uh
give the whole analysis um
okay but first of all let's let's assume
uh
let's assume we're proving this main
lemma
then you can you have these two
parameters c and d and now you can like
play around which parameters c and d
give you uh the best outcome and
uh so in particular what you need is
that at the beginning of
your potential function it is at most
the threshold that you have to guarantee
and
then you know that at the end you're
reaching a vector that's going to have a
you cleaning length over about rhodam
and then the
uh the eigenvalues of of your matrix is
upper bounded by
c plus d times the length and
[Music]
then you get your bound and this is
epsilon over alpha this is the bound you
want to have
because this corresponds to a one over
alpha scaling of k
um maybe the only thing worth mentioning
here is that
uh if you look at these two parameters
for c
and d then actually uh
the bound that you start with
if you compare that with the bound that
you're ending with the only constant
factor away
so you are relaxing but you're not
really relaxing much
okay so here's a one-dimensional
intuition
um which
[Music]
yeah which is as follows imagine you
have a function dependent on
just a like a one dimensional parameter
x
and uh the function is one divided by s
minus
ax and think of s as being some
parameter
so what happens if you do gaussian
updates
if you have such a function so this
function it's going to have a pole
somewhere
and now if you do a gaussian update
constructed in particular means that
expectation you are where you
when you started um then the following
happens the change the expected change
in the potential function
it's going to be proportional to the
square of your step size
and moreover it's proportional to
the um second derivative of your
function
okay now
um maybe you already saw in the
potential function that we kind of
kind of relaxing things a little bit in
every iteration as x gets longer
so let's see how that works imagine
you do sort of a second operation you
uh you shift the uh parameter s
by let's say the square of the step size
what is actually the change in the
potential function
well the potential function changes by
something that's
also proportional to the square of the
the step size so that's good
uh but it's proportional to the first
derivative
uh and uh we would have loved to see the
second derivative here then we could
have just killed this term here
um there's a second problem is that
if you can see that if you're as you're
getting closer to the pole
the second derivative actually blows up
a lot faster than the first derivative
uh it means that there may be regions of
x where uh
sort of the decrease you're getting from
the shift can can kill the
expected increase uh from your update
uh but it will not work everywhere
particularly we have to be
far enough from the pole okay
and if we go back to the statement of
the main lemma then
this is what what is the assumption
tells us is that
we need the potential function to be
small enough so that
the update works okay
um okay
um i can go to my open problem sections
now this is sort of a
decent place to stop otherwise it would
take another 10 minutes
james uh
yeah i mean you have uh we can take
questions now if you want to state some
open problems go ahead
or if anyone has questions
uh yeah so there's some calculations
that i unfortunately have to
uh i'll tell you okay so here's uh
here's a
uh very interesting open problem that
i wasted a lot of time on and the
setting is that
um c3 you take inmate phrases
uh symmetric in uh and by matrices
and the eigenvalues are between minus
one and plus one
and um i'm looking at sort of the
analogous body
this is the uh the body of sort of good
fractional colorings
so that uh the eigenvalues
that i get by using sines x i they are
between minus root n and plus root
and i know unfortunately very little
about this body
what i would really love to show is that
the existing plus minus one coloring in
a constant scaling of k uh
this is a conjecture that has been made
at least by random omega
um okay
let's say i'll be happy with something a
lot more modest at this point
i would love to know whether the
gaussian measure of this set k
is decently large can you give me any
lower bound of the form
uh 2 to the minus constant times that
and actually something weaker would
already be very interesting
can you at least show me that the width
of this body is large
uh large would mean constant absolutely
and i completely failed
proving any or answering any of these
questions so i'll uh
stop you thank you
thanks uh uh
yeah so we have time for maybe one quick
question if anyone has one um
uh yeah maybe
uh yeah let's maybe go to a break i have
a question but
it's a bit long-winded so i might just
ask you privately uh
so we start again in uh in five minutes
with uh sora stock